what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be giving you a lesson on how to bail
so do you guys have a date you don't
want to go on you have a class you want
to miss you have a family function that
you don't want to go to
here's the lesson for you
so
when you're gonna bail last minute
especially the most important thing that
you have to have is
an excuse
now this could be a variety of things
okay
let's start with let's start with the
number one excuse that we all have used
the past three years
I don't care if you're young old I don't
care if you're a good person or a bad
person every single person has used
coven
how many false positive tests have you
taken a picture of
to send to your employer
don't want to go to a date coven
don't want to go out coven I got covered
it gives you two weeks
of being able to miss you want to miss
school
covid because the last two years nobody
was playing with Cobin nobody wanted to
get covet or spread covet see just
casually
get covered okay not get covered just
you know tell people the next excuse
now this is similar you can use strep
throat
stomach flu
personally I like the stomach flu
because it gives me like two to three
days to like oh no sorry I can't
now the next
now the next
biggest excuse that we use traffic
you know what city you live in you know
in London there's always traffic I'm
looking at you blessing
tells me he's an hour and a half late
today because of traffic
because of it or
the Queen's death
you know damn well you didn't know the
lady
you know damn well you're not going to a
funeral
you know damn well you're not torn up
you know damn well what time traffic is
every single day
but
when you're running late these excuses
work
and
you know I have a couple more
on top of that
grandma's funeral
now
your grandma's been dead for three years
she had a funeral at one point so it's
not lying to say I'm sick period or no
sorry I can't go period
I had my grandma's funeral period now
it's not a lie
but this is how honest people lie
excuse now why do excuses work you're
thinking people aren't stupid they know
you didn't have coveted three times last
year
they know you don't get the stomach flu
every other week they do know what time
traffic is
Queen's death didn't really affect you
your grandma didn't die five times in
the past four years how many grandmas
you got
how many grams
but the reason the reason this stuff
works okay is because
people give you the benefit of the doubt
so
you might know
so
you might think well they probably don't
have covid but let's give them the
benefit of the doubt in case they do
because I'll look like a real [ __ ] if
I say your grandma didn't die three
times last year
the Queen's death really didn't affect
you oh we forgot the other one Mental
Health
[Laughter]
I need a mental health day what is a
mental health day
you can't you can't be depressed every
single day or if you are you shouldn't
be employed
but because we don't know what's going
on in their life then we always use
these phrases you don't know what's
going on in their life
you don't know what someone's going
through that is given to you by people
that love excuses
when we go to war
does the commander say you can take a
mental health day
does he say well your grandma died you
can't fight in the front lines no oh
whatever shit's important there is no
excuse
but
because you know there's nice people out
there
they give people the benefit of the
doubt like me blessing
now
stop
is you offer and
apology
so you start this apology with
I'm so sorry
insert excuse I got covet or there was
still let's do there was traffic
because you you won't say I had my
grandma's funeral it'll never happen
again
I guess you could but but you do so I'm
sorry
um their insert excuse
and then stage number four
stage number four which is gaslighting
it'll never happen again
so sorry
you say I'm sorry insert excuse it'll
never happen again
and then you just keep inserting it so I
had covid it'll it'll never happen again
or you just say I had coven because you
know they can't they can't really argue
I had strep by the stomach flu health
issues Mental Health
you know or traffic it'll never happen
again
um or the other one I forgot this one
I'm going
through
a lot
what are you going there you live in the
West
you live at one of the greatest times to
be alive with the higher standard of
living ever
go talk to the people in third world
countries
but they're going through a lot they'll
still show up to work
they'll still show up to work but
that's where the gaslighting comes in
because you know damn well you're going
to do it again
you know what's going to happen again
you know you ain't showing up tomorrow
you know you're gonna bail next week you
know you're gonna have someone cover
your ship shift you know you're not
turning in that assignment so Gaslight
okay and you just keep gaslighting until
the final step
foreign
ghost
at some point
you know you're about to get fired you
know you're about to lose that friend
You Know You're Gonna Lose That Girl
so at that time when you feel like you
have used every single excuse you could
think of
they're done giving you the benefit of
the doubt you can apologize
and they know you're full of [ __ ] you
can't Gaslight them anymore
it's time to find a new job
it's time
to find a new school or a new teacher a
new class whatever it is in life that
you're ghosting
um
shout out to my psychology class this
year I've used a lot of these
um
but yeah so if you ever want to bail on
something these are the five steps
and I think that's about covered let me
know in the comments what you think
don't forget to like the video subscribe
to the channel class
dismissed